my next guest is someone whose work
helps guide and inform our conversations
about race and racism in america don
lemon is an award-winning journalist
and the host of cnn tonight he is also
the author of a book
this is the fire what i say to my
friends about racism
the title is a reference to james
baldwin's famous book the fire next time
don thank you so much for being on the
show i am so excited
to talk to you i mean this whole year
has been insane
and we will get to the book in just a
minute but your career in cnn
uh with cnn took took off in atlanta
right
and we saw last night another instance
of young white men
a young white man allegedly committing
mass murder it's still early in the
investigation and there's a lot we don't
know yet
but i just want to get your reaction to
what has happened
in the city of atlanta which i know
means so much to you
well you're right we don't know um
exactly what happened but
it most of the victims are asian
and certainly our hearts and our prayers
and our thoughts can go out to the asian
community and
um and also wanting to protect the asian
community
because none of this happens in a bubble
we do live
in a country and we do live in a time
now where anti-asian bias is up
and asian attacks are on the rise as
well
and it is it i think it can be traced
back to
the language around the pandemic and how
how certain people especially
marginalized people uh have been treated
and were treated and still are but we're
treated by the last administration so
um we'll look to see what happens with
the investigations arlena
but we can certainly want to offer our
protection and love for our asian
american brothers and sisters i think
that's fair
absolutely you said the racial reckoning
you write about in your book is spurring
a backlash and you spoke to
the way in which the previous president
talked about
the covid virus in racist terms and
we've also been covering for weeks
republican efforts to suppress the vote
so it's coming from
all sides uh in in terms of the backlash
what does it look like how does it feel
and why is it happening
the backlash you mean from the book or
just from covering these topics
the the backlash from the racial
reckoning okay
um well look
i think that i think this is you know
having a conversation with a friend who
said
um who's older than me a little bit
older than me and said i haven't lived
through anything like this
really since the civil rights movement
since the 1960s and
and really the early 1970s mostly the
1960s
so i think that the backlash
is only coming from i believe the last
throws
of white supremacy and
i don't think it's the end of life above
racism or or i don't think it's going to
be the end of white supremacy anytime
soon but i believe that we're in the
last throws of it the last messages of
that
and you could you and it is directly um
it can be seen directly in the vigor
that we see so many people now freely
being openly racist
and and white supremacists trying to
take over the capital
uh insurrection so we see people
fighting
fighting tooth and nail because they
know that the jig is up
they know that the demographics are lean
in this country by 2040 2045 it's gonna
be a minority majority country
and so they're fighting tooth and nail
to hang on to power and to try to
to to be the preeminent voice and um
and have the power in this country and i
think they know that it's over
and that this president the former
president
was their ticket it was their you know
meal ticket to to continue that
and that's not happening so they're mad
they're angry because they thought that
they could
either vote him in and one when he
wasn't voted in then they thought they
could overturn an election to get him in
by sheer will will which was privilege
and entitlement and that did not happen
yeah i think the privilege and
entitlement on display that day
was so so blatantly obvious i mean every
you know i think that day on the show we
just talked about every single
step they took into the chamber was
white privilege it was just like
okay we're just gonna walk right up into
the capitol and walk back out and go
home
you can do that i was like i was not
aware that you could do that
um and to see black people killed for
just
living just walking but don't but the
whole idea is early that
even that was you're talking about the
insurrectionists but the whole idea from
lawmakers and
quite frankly even from some in law
enforcement that these people weren't
going to be violent or that they were
going to support law enforcement
they weren't going to break any laws
simply because they were white trump
supporters
that was also entitlement and and
privilege as well
because no one ever thought that they
would react that that way and we had
been saying for
years right i've seen you on television
i've read your work saying for years
listen
white supremacy is dangerous especially
white
right-wing terrorism in this country
it's dangerous and when we say it
we're called race faders right uh we're
called um
we had trump derangement syndrome and
none of that was true we were simply
stating what was true
and the results that have been in many
investigations
um by the fbi even the head of the fbi
says
white right wing white extremist
terrorism
the number one terror threat in this
country and it has been for some time
and people have just
simply chose to ignore it ignore it
that's entitlement and that's privilege
one of the things i think is important
is during the 2016 campaign
uh we have this big conversation i
remember with within the campaign
about what was happening it was right
around when when donald trump hired
steve bannon so hillary did a big speech
about how he was emboldening white
supremacists and white nationalists
and i remember the phrase normalizing
racism was was sort of the one that
everybody stuck to in terms of
describing what was going on because it
felt like he was making it okay to be a
bigot in public
again and nobody would say anything to
you nobody would say it was
inappropriate for you to be behaving
that way
uh talk to speak to the issue of how
trump
gave permission to to people who have
bigoted views about
all types of people in this country and
he gave them
just permission to be that out in the
open loud and proud and and bigoted
well he co-signed them and i would say
that he was white supremacist and
bigot's greatest
imprimatur in the last decade because he
he gave them the seal of approval and
signed off on their racism and their
bigotry and he made them think that it
was okay for them
now it used to be that people would do
it in shadows and they would do it in
sheets
and then once one year later you're
talking about 2016
a year later after the election the
culmination of that and the evidence
is of course charlottesville where we
saw people marching
in by broad moonlight uh with tiki
torches
saying jews will not replace us and
blood and soil
and they were marching to take their
country back and to
continue on with signs and symbols
of the confederacy and so he
he gave them legitimacy and said that it
was okay for them to come out of the
shadow
and be able to do what they wanted
wanted to do and to continue their
racist bigoted work right out in the
open
that's what donald trump did and to say
and and did it
with a not not even with a wink and a
nod sometimes it was
but broadly he said you know tell police
officers
don't treat them nicely you know do that
very fine people on both sides what do
you think that meant
when you tell a a nazi a neo-nazi and
the white supremacist said
they're fine people too co-signing
especially when you're when you speak
about black people
or colin kaepernick countries in africa
in in
demeaning terms um and then you you
speak about white supremacists
uh as very fine people i mean it says a
lot um
one of the things that your book will
help do i hope um
is spark conversations about race
because one of the things that i think
happens all the time
is you know a lot of white folks will be
like well what's the right way to have
this conversation what book should i
read
you know what what ted talk should i
watch so that i can have the right
conversation the right way about race
and then they don't end up having the
conversation they just like prepare to
have the conversation
perfectly and then they don't get to it
because it's uncomfortable
to really just sit with the reality
of what race is in this country how can
we really just have this conversation
where where should we start once again
you're right on the mark and people want
to listen
um people want to give lip service and
sometimes
if sometimes they want to give your
service and sometimes they want to
i guess ins they i guess it's
genuine i hope that it's genuine but
then when you tell them what they need
to do when you give them
the prescription and you tell them how
they need to
listen and and the tools they don't want
to do the work
so what you have to do is do the work
zerlina you have to do the work
and that starts by listening that also
starts by having relationships with
people who don't look like you
and and i find that most people in this
country especially white people live in
communities that
where people look and think exactly like
them and not until there is
something like briana taylor or ahmad
aubry
uh or they hear very fine people on both
sides and they go wait a minute well
maybe he didn't mean that
and then all of a sudden you see a
george floyd dying in the street in
front of your very eyes
while you're in quarantine in the middle
of a deadly pandemic and you go oh my
gosh you can't ignore it
and then maybe then will you be open and
vulnerable enough to say
okay now i see it now i get it
but there has to be action after that
you have to start with relationships
right
you act you actually have to start
admitting that there is a problem that
you may have
i try to tell people because it's easier
for them to to
digest um that you may have a racial
blind spot or some racial blind spot
or in the very end maybe you're a bigot
or maybe a racist
but you have to be open to that but you
also have to be open i think the biggest
thing
relationships and then doing the work
you can't say
what do i need to do and then and then
when i tell you say well that's
impractical
it's impossible to meet new right for
that okay
well we can send a rover all the way to
mars a machine to mars and get pictures
back
we can put a man on the moon but you
can't step
out of your car in the school line the
you drop off line at school and invite
the latino lady
who is who goes to class with your kid
over for a barbecue so that you can get
to know someone
who's not like you you can't invite the
sister who's in front of you in the car
for you know a picnic or to i don't know
go shopping or do whatever you can't do
that
that's not impossible that is pop that
is possible
so uh you have to do the work that's
right
yeah and it really does start with
relationships one of the things that i
love about
my radio co-host jess mcintosh um is
that
she's she's sort of like we we joke that
she's like my white interpreter
because you know we we move throughout
the world in the before times together
we're like a
you know a biracial broad city if you
will where like you know a black girl
you know a white um a white woman
walking around
uh new york city you know with our
shenanigans and
she would see the microaggressions
happen to me so it's really
in interesting to watch a white person
see what it's like to be you because
they're just spending a lot of time with
you out in public
and she's like this is what your life is
like you know people cutting you in line
and yelling at you
and you know just all those ways in
which you're demeaned as a human being
because you
you're you exist in a black body so
how do we how do we get white folks to
understand
the lived experience of people who don't
aren't born white who don't walk around
in the world in white skin because
it is different the experience is
different every aspect
of how you engage with people
and how people treat you is different
based on a choice you didn't make you
came
out you're here i'm black you're black
you know we just showed up
i give examples in the book about that
and it's not
and what i want people to understand
it's not just you know
it's not just poor people it's not just
a certain section of the black
population that you deem you know are
people who live in a certain kind of
home or neighborhood
and what have you it's all it's all
people of color
i say that you know racism is racism you
know
um since we've been doing the meghan
markle thing racism is
racism whether you live in a castle or
you live in a shack
it doesn't matter it's racism and i give
examples about that in the book and
there was one i wasn't sure i was going
to include because
i felt like it was i said wow this was
too privileged i should not put that in
there it was about an experience that i
had
in a high-end shop recently during the
pandemic and that is one of the most
relatable things to people
who have read the book they say you know
what i never really had have to think
about that and that really opened my
eyes i was just going out
to and walking and i saw some cutting
boards that i needed for my countertop
because i don't want to stain my
my countertops that i worked really hard
to buy right and
in the house that i worked really hard
to buy and when i got there i bought
them and the guy told me i couldn't
enter the store
because it was the middle of quarantine
and as i walked back by the store later
that day
there was there were people in there
shopping and i said
well he told me i couldn't shop no i
don't know if it was racism i don't know
what it was
but i certainly felt it and i ended up
i ended up reaching out to my black
friends and my white friends
and every single person was like that's
some shady you know what
and i didn't cause a stir i just
returned the cutting boards and said
you know i walked by and there were some
people shopping in the store afterwards
you told me i couldn't
i don't know what it is but anyways that
doesn't fit my home and i would like to
return it
so i give examples about that but i say
in the books arlena
that you know when you're when you're
about to run a race and you it's ready
set
go that black people live and set
it's like ready and then you're set and
you're always on edge that
is going to pop off and you live
basically in a paranoia
all the time that someone could possibly
discriminate against you
or that someone could call the police on
you
and someone could tell you that you're
not supposed to be in a place where you
are supposed
to that happened to me on sunday i was
jogging by the river in new york city
this lady is standing in the middle of
the pathway everybody's running
you know i'm like the only black person
you know
not in sight but you know it's new york
city but in in the area where i was
and so i'm running and just jogging
along and she's running the running path
and just started looking around
and then i like i i wait i'm like okay
she's going to go right i'm going to go
left okay now she's going right
and then finally she bumps into me and i
go excuse me and she goes
come on and i said ma'am you were
i tried i was trying to get out of your
way she goes you should not even be
running here i said
it's a running man and it was her sense
of entitlement and she looked at me
and her first thought was that i wasn't
supposed to be there
and that i was doing something wrong not
that she wasn't paying attention
not that she was under some spell
that this that it belonged to her and
she can move and be
on a running path that's like standing
in the middle of a street where traffic
is going
and telling a car that's going by in a
50 mile an hour zone
hey why did you hit me
you're not supposed to be here that's
the spell of racism
that has to be broken that's a spell of
racism like
you get a sharon osborne or someone who
makes
the uh act about their grievance
rather than about the actual act of
racism itself
that's the spell of racism and it it has
to be broke
i mean i feel like you know it's it's
sort of a karen mentality we've been
talking about
um you know the cairns during the
pandemic but i think in
in part what you describe is that sense
of entitlement to be able to
tell any black person what to do where
to stand
where to be and that no matter who they
are as long as they are white and you
are black
they have that power and that is that is
what they're learning
as children i mean that is what our sort
of culture and our society
sort of steeped in white supremacy
that's the result is
is people growing up being like they can
tell you to move because they are white
and you are black
um but it's 20 21. um and in america i
feel like
you know we have to evolve i feel like
this last year especially
uh in the pandemic it was so uniquely
american to have a race
reckoning in the middle of the pandemic
like germany didn't have a race
reckoning
you know what i mean like i don't think
france had a race reckoning
america though america they had time
uh for a race reckoning because the
police continued to kill
just as many black people as they did
the year before when there was no
pandemic
so just reflect on the last year because
this book is so aptly timed
uh to allow for people to have these
conversations because that's the only
way we fix it
uh is if people think about things
differently
differently think about race differently
and then have conversations
and change behavior do the work did you
know did you
did you say that the the pre-times or
the before times is that what you call
before the
before the pandemic yeah that just jess
says that too
i steal all of my good lines from just
macintosh
[Music]
we did have
i have also heard people saying you know
don it's so heavy right now
can i just go back to being snarky on
instagram and i just want to
i just want to smack him i know
physically i can't but it's like
why don't you take what happened
to and and absorb that and allow it to
uh help you become a better person and a
better countryman
and to create a better country for all
of us because in
in the book i also write about you talk
about karen's i write about amy cooper
and
and christian cooper in central park
what happened with the dog off the leash
and then she called the cops
um and i say you know if we don't solve
this problem then someone is going to
come back with a bigger dog
and so then that bigger dog the evidence
of that was
um saying that the election was stolen
and then the bigger dog after that was a
capital insurrection on january 6th
and until we actually really deal with
this and stop worrying about being
snarky on instagram
um then someone is going to come back
with an even with an even bigger dog and
what's that dog going to look like
is that going to be an overthrow of the
entire entire government
is that going to be martial law from
from you know trump supporting
insurrectionists
white supremacist neo-nazis i don't know
but before any of that happens
why don't we work it out and establish
some relationships and do some of the
work
where we can do it with like-minded
people and people who want to change
before we are forced into something like
a civil war or
something terrible even more terrible
than what we've seen before
i know it feels it feels like we could
go one way which is the way towards the
light
or the other way which is back towards
the darkness
um and in sort of the ugly parts of our
history
or maybe even unprecedented things in
terms of the martial law piece because
that's a real
that's a real danger okay last question
in the last minute
uh we were talking before we we came on
air
about just the pandemic and how it's
hard every single day
emotionally mentally mental health is a
big issue right now
just speak to to how you are trying to
you know wake up every day and and just
survive a pandemic which
there is no rule book for unfortunately
there was nothing on amazon
that i could purchase to tell me how to
do this right
well i honestly as erlina i'm glad you
asked that question because for me
the last five years have been really
tough it's been the personal attacks
have been really
tough from the person who's in the
highest office the negativity the
toxicity
not only on social media but in your
personal life having to look over your
shoulder
uh to you know what crazy person is
coming and then just the depression
because the
the country was going in in such a
negative direction
and then on top of that we have a deadly
pandemic where we can't be with our
loved ones and friends and have
personal interactions um it's been tough
there's been
way too much sleeping for me way too
much isolation
there's been a lot of therapy um i've
even had to
you know think about antidepressants and
all of those things
but um the the the november election
gave me hope writing this book also was
a great release for me
and so i don't want to get ahead of
myself i feel like we're in a better
place and we're going in a better place
and you're absolutely right
that we're on a precipice right now we
can go one way or the other
and i hope we go towards a positive
direction that we go in the direction of
a more perfect union
which is the promise of this country
instead of a regressive
division divided uh way
where white supremacists and bigots get
the best of us
i think we're going to go the right way
i hope so and this book will help i
i really do believe that i think i think
this book will help as well and i think
that's so relatable because i think a
lot of people at home
they sometimes you you think you're the
only one that's having trouble you're
like
everybody else seems to be functioning
on the zoom calls why why am i the only
one having trouble and struggling
but i think a lot of people can connect
with the fact that this is universally
a very difficult experience so give
yourself a little grace that's my
like mantra that i say all the time to
just keep it moving
um so i don't get too stuck um john
lemon thank you so much for joining us
tonight
oh yeah even people like you and me who
have a platform right and people think
somewhat privileged right because we
have
um jobs right um and a lot of people
didn't during the pandemic people are
like really relying
on those stimulus checks and they think
like well you know
you why are you complaining everyone
can have an issue and so i think we
should give everyone as you said a
little bit of grace
for the leeway and understand and make
sure we take care of each other
well said exactly i agree 100
the book is this is the fire what i say
to my friends about racism don lemon
thank you so much for taking the time
out tonight
and please stay safe
hi i'm zerlina maxwell thanks for
checking out our channel on youtube
you can see more from zerlina by
clicking any of the videos on this
screen
and make sure you subscribe below to
stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories
thanks for watching